Marga wait wait wait beyond my team join
you join props throwing hunters it's
about switching like there you go
whatever oh you can go to someone can go
to spectators way house team press f1 go
to spectators then change team - I'm
gonna join okay someone else I just did
my props all right now mark join me I
guess okay
I can't it says there we go there we go
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta got it oh
my god who's still playing anyone I'm
playing its well wrong way just end it
yeah wait oh hey hey then what is that
thing oh I didn't play this one this is
totally different it looked like a dude
you look like a boob dang alright um my
views on sexual things like vaginas and
boobs that are a bit distorted
unfortunately my own now mine yeah we
win yeah you're gonna lose it's so dark
and it's already round 4 shut up
wait why is it round 4 I'm confused I
know idea what it be funny people just
had like 10-minute of short-term memory
loss it would be till we forgot that we
over anything on video like well
commonly we all did that for the last 10
minutes yeah thank you this oh man
someone starts up you kidding me I
climbed up the ladder right into my face
I was trying to get away from you people
oh never fine just saying I have evil
eyes I will
ever find me Oh yummy all right I have
never either yummy are we gonna make
this out of an eagle when you find me oh
wait I can they're not even close
what are you mark what yes my oat make
you do that throw your potato ball
directly at me that's stupid you're
stupid
I thought your stupid potatoes I do like
potatoes but that's nothing you like
potatoes oh yeah
can you say potato you say potatoes
normally potatoes potatoes they say when
you say potatoes I'm gonna say tomato
paedo tomato potato wait wha tomahto
tomahto
I'm so confused Sheree Komodo I guess we
can't sing the song then I was just
gonna sing the song with someone what's
the song oh oh
you guys are so cute oh my gosh I'm
almost there that was a mistake mistake
don't leave me alone here he's running
down the road you should really be
careful done you should look both ways
when running crossroads oh you a car no
no stop somewhere how's the car be won't
you so you're a little horny what are
you trying to stop ha ha ha ha too many
windows ha ha ha docking tables over
I'll get through these tables my god
that was my brother you just ran into oh
wait Marilee a chair I bet he's upstairs
on that thingy I'm looking out for him
I'm looking out bro I see you know what
the other person's behind a tree you
guys better leave me alone or before I
boil myself I'm in a traffic jam
and I thought I saw someone so someone
said oh my gosh I hurt someone's in a
tram huh yeah yeah Bob are you sure that
yamimash wasn't the secret element to
your team and that you're really bad I'm
sure I am bad I any hints or anything
I've given you a few look I've never
sucked never find a cone
all your problems okay listen I'm a
plant okay I'm up the plans down there
he died he fell and died grabbing me but
it didn't work well done well done in
our lives down to the basement how the
hell's the pressure oh wait wait wait
someone else who's it Bob do I look
right do I look correct oh my god yeah
yeah okay good
all right I thought I was gonna die
instantaneously okay can I pick anything
up like II does not work on this team
maybe we're just all of those props
everything everything I figured out the
cheat that lets me become everything we
are everywhere is quite something
Oh
why are you throwing my brother's around
up there on the table there why throwing
my bris around my braised yeah why don't
you uh those are my breads
get a nice ice cream eirick um love
these I just I know which one you are
mm-hmm get a um what I don't have
anything clever for mine maybe you
should stop keeping your emotions all
box oh I I don't like it but I'm kind of
useless I don't know why people keep me
around
you're all mates yeah yeah why don't you
stop and smell the flowers oh man
flowers I'm in some flowers right now
actually this
[Laughter]
what was that person's I didn't lose the
hell for breaking that plan just
shooting it shooting
what sound I I guess it's in the game
hey look up look up top there's a round
roll it around upstairs I got a big clue
come on you guys are so stupid I'm a
potted plant I potted plants okay I'm
just gonna shoot my rock and hope for
the best okay that's all part of - yes
way to shoot your rocket what way to
shoot your rocket at what a lot of stuff
I don't know kill yourself sorry you
gotta get one of us wait I think go
divider I think they're up there turn
around
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait you kind of suck at this game go
away I kept hoping I would magically
become invisible it didn't work now hey
mark where are you in the open the whole
time no not a single bit and the funny
thing is they destroyed basically
everything around me I was like man
right over there
yeah good Jodi don't satisfy that one
wait I get health somehow from killing
me yeah you always gain health when you
kills we do that - two points pretty
cool Ashley yeah why do I have negative
two points
oh no oh god I'm screwed
guys I'm screwed he's boy he's bull bull
pooping us fighting kill me this round
there's something's gone wrong
something's wrong with you because I'm
about to find you and kill me down there
with all those chairs
yes well I'm coming for you Wade why
can't I pick you up joke you know it's
gone up the ladder a barrel coming
awfully close I know I'm not that thing
that you just threw around there now
that's not me Silent Bob this current
section is clear up here I'm not there
I'm good I don't know if you guys could
handle me Mike second-guessing himself
no I'm just checking everything very
thorough that's fine you can do that
okay yeah whatever you're not up there
no I'm not up there yep okay hello
that's what you believe oh my yeah I
know right
that's very clever though oh no I
glitched so I'm kind of screwed icon
dude is that you know that what you see
him I like it there yummy I like it
thank you
I like don't do I don't even know what I
am it's very confusing I'm not quite
sure what you are
oh ma can you please shoot hey you can't
fool me I know when you're lying on the
other side my left foot singing the song
in the Sun thinking the song in the Sun
it's all the dark for sunlight oh my
gosh of your heart of my heart
yes only I'm not here my heart is not
here a red blood pounding vessel will go
on it is for you mock what's for me
Israelite blood vessel
wait wait what is your red blood
pounding vessel yeah
your zone your blood pounding zone I I
did not realize you guys were gonna be
in the open yet I I'm in a bad way Oh
Jude would you like some assistance oh
well I sort of got stuck and then I
realized I probably should not be a car
and being a little uh being a little
paranoid about them cheers a little lion
he's not no car just gonna throw a chair
yeah luckily I'm not but being a little
preoccupied with them cheers yeah yeah
yeah are you looking at those green
landmine thingies all right I'm gonna
steadily go down screw it just jump off
just screw it I fall anyway really did
you know how well you have to do is go
back where you were and kill me and
you'll get all that life back really
okay so bad thanks dumb fall
for the trolling they always do this who
always does what everyone everyone
trolls me oh come on your wave yamimash
already checked all those chairs yeah
super obsessed with those chairs and
tables now crap I'll tell you a hint
I'm not a chair or a table I didn't
believe you
no I applauded play I don't believe me
yeah a car or an orange barrel so what
the hell are you then that's pretty much
every there's lurking of all things left
we're all the way above looking down
upon he pours both of you are up yeah I
think so okay is that you right there
mark it might be okay all right
I think we're in this area I know you
guys uh ah come on what I can't just
missed every single brother oh god damn
it happen wait wait do you see me the
whole time or did you see me just at the
end there I saw you right at the end
yeah I move just a little bit more to
get a better view of what was going on I
could have stayed there it amazing were
you a green thing mark I was a green
thing and I was moving to get guys so
chair oh you I wish I could be a car I'm
so mad can't you know you can't be a car
oh the boats in the basement can you oh
yeah it's off limit
oh yeah the basements off limits I I
meant that's what I why does it say
hunters win it always says hunters win
hey Ben
that was I hunter
[Laughter]
next to each other that was haha
I thought the game hadn't started yet
you guys get lucky it was stocky stocky
huh love me long time suckie suckie yeah
[Music]
what is it
Oh God steel coat what
oh god I'm still bone I'm questioning my
decision but I guess the basement
I saw you wait I see you down there in
the coming up the stair the ladder it's
called a ladder anyway I'm gonna try and
replicate I think it was Bob did so
let's see if it works for me
really what a waste of effort you guys
are all over my area would you just move
on and search somewhere else yeah come
on I I ain't movin until I am a hundred
percent certain you're not huh well how
are you ever gonna be a hundred I don't
like that I can't pick things up and
chew everything it's on death oh don't
leave I was joking it's much funnier for
me when you walk around me the whole
time I'm just saying I end up just at
old tables and chairs I can't even move
right now so I'm kind of just stuck here
for the rest of it I hope mark dies so
he can see my really cheap ass spot
should I you want me to try to do you
want me to try to mess with him well you
know make it fun make it fun I can make
it fun oh no not me I'm on 5 HP oh no
not me
potato balls 5 8 we taught you anything
else if I fool oh hey hey hey
very well Tommy over here
[Laughter]
so mark is still alive even yeah Lisa
give you a hint I'll give you a hint
I'm on the street I sincerely am
breathing I try everything was trying to
get on the ladder and I didn't do it
where what are you wait or Bob what are
you a see it's spot right wait I know
what he is
wait I think it's not garage one you are
a big the orange thing I wait no you're
not nothing I do not know what you are
Bob I don't either
is this like ready and fast like sitting
in the open here on the street I'm not
oh your that oh my god right then wait
no wait no that's nice sorry I'm not
yellow I'm not orange I'm not black or
red a little great colored I'm not
asphalt colored either but I am greyish
yeah great gray ish yeah great I'll use
my camera to look around for this dude I
don't think that's never gonna know like
you are like sort of like cement colored
yeah actually seriously how could be I
didn't either until I tried it and got
stuck Bob move nope you're not moving
oh wait wait one do you're okay look
straight ahead no turn around no no no
okay OOP turn a little to your right
okay to shoot a rocket for God's sake
[Music]
can't even move oh wait no you moved a
little bit
no cheating Bob there's no cheating in
the open
it's what I have a clue yes cement
colored on the street
[Music]